if you don't like what i'm about to say
in this video don't get so worked up
it's just a joke bro
[Music]
so uh if you follow my channel regularly
yes yes
i am still supposed to be on vacation
but here we are
so um when my video came out earlier
this week
addressing the current accusations and
issues and conversations surrounding
noel clarke and john barrowman and
doctor who
and their behavior and or how that does
or doesn't connect back to that show
there was something that came up both in
the live chat
when the video premiered and in the
comments
repeatedly enough that i need to address
it it's been a little while since this
has happened
where something comes up in the comments
frequently enough that i find myself
thinking okay well i can either respond
to all these and then copy and paste
that response or i can make a video
which maybe i should do given how many
people are saying this
now this is going to address
specifically the conversation about
john barrowman so we can forget noel
clark right now
um or you know we can forget him
permanently that's fine too
so here was the thing that would
frequently come up
it was this notion that what he did
which to reiterate
was various levels of self-exposure on
set
in a joking manner not in a manner that
really in any documentation that i can
find comes across
as sexually predatory but
as a joke i don't get why
that's funny but that's that was the
tone
of what john barrowman would do
now uh there is obviously now a
conversation going on about that
but one of the frequent defenses of him
basically boiled down to his co-workers
didn't complain
the people who have talked about that
publicly
laughed it off some and some have even
said some equivalent of
i thought it was hilarious it's fine
so i have a lot of problems
with those arguments being used to
excuse or downplay his actions
now let me be clear the difference in
motivation
between him and noel clark i said we
could forget i'm sorry
i'm just going to make the comparison
real quick does matter
because john barrowman's intention was
to get people to laugh
in a way that was ill-advised and very
unprofessional
and noel clark used his celebrity and
position of power to
actively take advantage of people
allegedly i'm not going to stick
allegedly on the john barrowman because
these are well-documented incidents with
many many many people having spoken
publicly
about it including himself so i don't
feel like allegedly
really fits there besides there's no
criminal allegations there are no clark
so we'll stick allegedly on there
so there are a number of reasons why
this defense
of him makes me very very uncomfortable
and very
unsettled to see it being deployed as
much as it is
now before i get into any of these let
me say i do
understand where a desire to use this
defense
in his favor comes from because
it's not hard to project yourself into
his shoes and think
well i mean i've got inside jokes with
my friends
we've got things that we joke about that
we say that aren't really
pc or shouldn't be said in public but
like everybody's okay with it and
you wouldn't want to be judged for those
kinds of interactions with people
that you know are okay with what you're
saying and
that can make you hesitant to judge
someone else when you feel like it's a
similar situation
the first thing to address if that's the
kind of connection you're making
is that john barrowman was not with a
group of friends hanging out in an
apartment
he was on a set he was working
these were professional environments and
no matter
what you think about whether or not what
he did was funny
it sure as hell was not professional
so there's already an inherent problem
because this
isn't just a group of friends hanging
out so to think of it in those terms
is a bad comparison
that's the first thing the second thing
is i find it very unsettling
that people would cite a few specifics
of individuals who have said oh yeah
he'd do that whatever
[Music]
and even when there are some people who
have gone on record and basically said
that
there's a big problem with presuming
that means everybody was okay because
first of all
not everyone who is on that set has
commented there are plenty people who
haven't and i'm not just talking about
other co-stars
something that almost never comes up in
these conversations
is that the actors and the director are
not the only people on the set
there are lighting technicians there's
the camera crew
they're the sound engineers there are
production assistants just running
around and handling
whatever needs to be done at any given
moment and these people's opinions are
basically never asked
not by fandoms not by journalists
they are always just assumed because we
don't see them in front of the screen
other like a background feature we don't
have to think about them no you do
so even if every single actor who was
sharing a
scene with john barrowman was okay
when he did these sorts of things that
doesn't mean that
all the other professionals on a
professional work set
were okay with it that is a very
bad assumption to make because you don't
know that and to take a couple of
instances of people who
totally were and say therefore nobody
was offended you do not know that
now do i know for a fact that they were
offended
well no but i'm not going to pretend
like i know that
so please don't you pretend like you
know they weren't
now somewhat related to this people
would also say you know
in addition to you know what some of his
co-stars have said publicly laughing
about it very jokingly seemed to think
it was funny
there would be people saying
well nobody ever complained first of all
you don't have to complain about
something for it to be wrong
let's get that out there and second of
all in an environment especially like
a film shoot there is a disproportionate
power balance and there are lots and
lots
of people who even if they do feel
uncomfortable
are not going to complain about it
because they know they are lower on the
totem pole
than the person whose behavior makes
them uncomfortable
and for them to talk about it is to
endanger their careers
now again we should be well aware of
this
because of how many people were silent
for so
long about so many figures that we have
now come to know
as monsters a big part of why so few
spoke out
is because they knew they mattered less
and that if something came down to well
we either get rid of one of our in front
of the camera stars
or discipline them or make a fuss or
we just quietly get rid of this extra
this one scene actor this grip
what have you guess what they're gonna
do
that is why people don't speak so
presuming that silence and a lack of
complaints
from people on set also means everyone
was fine with it is
also an incredibly false assumption but
you know what
let's for a moment engage with a
hypothetical
let's just say for the sake of argument
that every single person
on set in front and behind the camera
was
not only okay with john barrowman
whipping his junk out in fact found it
humorous
let's for a moment assume that that is
in fact true that there was not
a single person offended and everybody
genuinely not uncomfortably but
genuinely left and thought it was funny
it still wouldn't be okay in that
situation
because as i said this is not a group of
friends hanging out
this is a professional set
and when someone behaves like that
and is not talked to and is not
disciplined is not
simply told hey please don't do that
anymore
then that becomes a mark that
signals to whoever is aware that this
happened
which i'll remind you all is actually a
big chunk of the fandom because these
stories have been getting shared
it signals to them that there are some
times
that it is acceptable
to whip out your junk in front of
strangers
who did not ask or give you clearance or
consent
to do that it's not
it is objectively not
o k to do
in a professional working environment
and to do it and to say well it was okay
because everyone was comfortable
not only sends a message to other people
that sometimes
it is okay but it's going to allow a lot
of people to do mental gymnastics and
self-justification where they go oh
well everybody's laughing everybody
seems to be okay with this
so i definitely didn't do anything wrong
when i decided to do that
this is not acceptable behavior in the
environment he was doing it
it's arguable that it's not acceptable
behavior under any circumstances
i'm not quite prepared to go that way
because like i said
if you're with a group of people of
friends and you want to have those kinds
of
moments jokes things and you know that
everyone is comfortable with it first of
all
i would ask do you truly know that truly
but hypothetically maybe okay but these
incidents were on
set it's not
okay and to act as if as long as
everyone
who was there was okay with it then it's
fine is to pretend as if morals are
always relative and there are not some
things that as a society we need to put
a moral
stand and draw a line and say no
actually that's not okay
because while i do not believe any of
the people who are making any of these
arguments in my
comments would have made this next sleep
it is the logical leap
and the logical extension to say well
it's totally okay
to say something racist or sexist
or transphobic so long as you are
certain
that the people who are hearing you are
okay with it
no no it's still not because
these are beliefs and stereotypes
and harmful notions that should not
be repeated or parroted they are harmful
by
existing normalizing a
man exposing himself in a work
environment
is harmful by existing regardless of
whether or not
anybody present at that moment
actually had a problem with it now let
me be clear i am not here to try and
condemn john berman any harsher than i
did in that original video
but i did not make this excuse for him
the only allowance that i granted him
was that the most recent incident
i was able to find dated from 2008
and he did not appear from my research
to have had new incidents since then
so the degree to which i am
at present barring new realizations
prepared to give him benefit of the
doubt
is on the basis of he seems to have
stopped
and grown and changed
but i did not defend him on the basis of
people were okay with it and everybody
laughed and i never
would and i am really unsettled by how
many people i saw
do that some things
are not okay objectively
and some things even if they are okay in
certain circumstances are absolutely not
okay
in a working environment which was where
these things took place
the people present at the time do not
have to be offended for it to be wrong
this is why allyship is important
this is why people who are in oppressed
minorities will tell their friends who
are not part of that same group
hey if you hear somebody saying things
that despair just please speak up even
if we're not there
it's why as a queer person i will tell
anyone who's trying to be
an ally who is heterosexual and
cisgender
if you hear somebody being
transphobic homophobic any of these
things
even if it's a joke even if it's
something that you've let them get away
with
in the past speak up even if i'm not
there
the absence of the people taking offense
does not make
certain actions or statements or beliefs
or jokes okay
that's it thank you very much for
listening
i had to get this off my chest it was
really unsettling me
this video was made possible by my
patreon
supporters get rewards at every tier
there should be a link up there i would
greatly appreciate it
it's what enables me to actually keep
doing this it is my living
but even if you're not able to do that
politely even if you disagree with me
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it and there is the
usual stuff
likes share subscribes they help me out
against the algorithm
which is not consistently very kind to
me
so that would be appreciated but you
also don't have to do that
as passionate as i get about these
things i'm not
trying to tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you are
the council
and i'm just running the meetings and
until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]